hello everyone and welcome back from the
break
I think the first session set the stage
nicely for our next guests and
discussion topic on how a gene therapy
cdmo has managed to sustain growth in an
unusually challenging environment
my name is Betty Wu and I'm the vice
president and general manager for cell
and gene therapy at Thermo Fisher
Scientific
the business I lead leverages our total
company capabilities in selling gene
therapy to help solve customer
challenges in this rapidly evolving
field
with customers like viralgen our shared
vision is to increase the accessibility
of these life-saving therapies to
patients
today it's my pleasure to welcome Javier
Garcia kogoro CEO of viralgen an
industry-leading cdmo specializing in
the production of aav viral vectors
based in Spain Javier is an entrepreneur
an investor with more than 35 years of
experience in health care and the
biopharmaceutical industry
he's also president and founder of
Columbia Venture partners and co-founder
of Columbia Children's Foundation
now I'll let Javier share more details
on himself in viraldton but I hope to
also get a sense of him as a person and
how he finds the time to recharge and
gain energy and inspiration for the
wonderful work he does
but first let me tee up a little on
viralton
this cdmo was formed in 2017 in response
to the unmet need for the manufacturing
of Gene therapies and the borrow gym
team brings Decades of technology and
Drug development experience to support
best-in-class service offerings to the
gene therapy Market
in this discussion Javier will share
practical learnings and insights on how
viralgen navigated through the pandemic
how he and his organization were able to
sustain operations over the past 24
months and equally important the lasting
changes that will shape viral jyn's
growth strategy in the future
with that a very warm welcome to Javier
Garcia
thank you very it's my pleasure to be
here and glad to be here with all of you
today
thanks Javier we're looking forward to
hearing your outlook on the growth and
success as a cdmo
um can we start by you telling us a
little bit about yourself in viral gin
okay yes for sure um let me start with
my my story I've been in this industry
for more than 35 years I started my way
in ilali many years ago when I did a
number of things from Information
Technology to
such marketing and Business Development
um
in
2012 I left Lily and I created my own
business and the business was really
related to creating value around finding
opportunities in the biotech sector and
to develop those properly with an idea I
started the conversation partners that
was focused on two main areas about the
time we saw my partner and myself were
very critical for the for the business
was was around new Therapeutics that
were coming from universities and we're
really going to change the way medicine
was going to be seen in the future and
the second was very important we
realized that the product and and the
production were very close so we were
seeing them more and more all these
Technologies all these advances really
require a totally different approach in
manufacturing so we decided to invest in
power in manufacturing and that was very
unique at the time because very few
people were looking at Manufacturing in
the traditional Venture Capital World
they were mostly talking let's work on
therapists let's work on biomarkers
let's work on other tools that other VCS
were specialized in manufacturing but
they were not specializing in therapies
so we were one of the few ones in Europe
who really embraced both things and I
think that was a key factor for us of
success so in that journey of really
understanding Technologies we invested
in a number of gene therapy applications
in a number of interoper fields and we
happened to meet Dr Joseph moski
early in 2015 and understood much better
how the technology was working and all
his contributions to science that were
related to the therapies but also
related to how this therapies could be
delivered to customers to patients in
particular through Manufacturing so with
a conversation with him and his team we
realize that in the future they're going
to be a big gap in terms of a
manufacturing capacity and capabilities
to really make these Technologies be
accessible to people and that's the
origin of value in 2017 we decided to
create a bargain because as value due to
musky and filamental health really have
a big and rich portfolio of solutions
but they we were lacking the
manufacturing capacity but the idea at
the time was not too early to
manufactory for a company portfolio to
doing manufacturing across the board to
be sharing that with other groups and
that's how balding was created as a
German venture between Australia and
Columbus Venture partners with the idea
of becoming a reference cdmo in the
field we are started in Southwestern
almost five years ago with five people
and a lot and right now we are 350
people and we have grown tremendously
and we have had a very very interesting
Journey which we decided to start very
slow uh focusing on rmd batches on
critical watches and that was our first
approach let's go and solve the problem
of the scalability from the lab into
toxicology clinical watches let's
understand how we can really transfer
the technology from for us video Pro 10
how we can build the team that can
really Embrace that and that's how we
spend the first two years of the of this
project uh that country was successful
we were able to validate and accredited
the first room we are created two more
rooms and in 2019 we decided that it was
time to start going Beyond and many
customers at the time that we had start
asking okay how do you go what are you
going to do whenever we're going to
phase three and Commercial however to
support your uh the project and we start
planning the commercial manufacturing
facility so
2019 was the planning year for that then
2020 came the pandemic has started and
here we are with a big project
and the pandemic we were very very uh
lucky that the we were able to work for
all the time on the pandemic and we were
able to work thanks to the commitment of
the the employees thanks to the
flexibility of the of the of the
government thinking that well this is
something that is going to be important
for society and we cannot slow down
those things so we're able to work and
in 16 months we stopped we went from a
Plainfield
a lot here in San Sebastian into a full
commercial manufacturing built and ready
to be validated so there was a
magnificent effort from everybody and
where we are right now is we are in the
process of getting the accreditation for
the first module and we're going to have
that meditation by the end of this year
we'll have the presentation for the 31st
2000 liters
sweets and from that in that at that
time we will have them
um celebrity to do from two liter one
into two thousand is a run and scale all
these things so when I look at this
business uh hand side and I look at and
the amount of work has been phenomena
but we come back to the origin and the
vision that we have at the time we said
well you bring the right technology
you're in the right people and you
iterate the right right support from the
local community you have um social story
The the thing that you need to do to do
in order to make this thing happen is to
rely on the knowledge that you're going
to build and how this knowledge can be
applicable to all the different stages
of the project I'm also working with
customers to really learn how to solve
the problem so it's a cultural change at
the same time you bring customers you
have to start uh understanding how
you're going to translate to them how
the technology can work for them and
also they need to tell you what are they
need so you can marry those things so it
has a very interesting process and I can
go in more detail with my examples of
the evolution because at the beginning
everybody wants Vector I want Vector I
want prep for my uh animal models I want
to have production for my face one trial
but in reality
that need is going to be more complex
it's going to be much more comprehensive
it's not the product it's the knowledge
and his ability to really support a
registration process that is important
for customers and that's what we are
focused on focusing right now
so incredibly interesting uh Genesis to
the company and the journey that you've
been on is just um incredible
um
can we talk a little bit more about the
challenges and opportunities the
pandemic has created for viral gin and
more broadly speaking for the cdmo
industry
specifically perhaps which ones do you
anticipate will have the more lasting
impact to your business
well the pandemic has shown to us in
very very many lessons on some of them
are probably will still capturing I'm
trying to to understand as I said before
we work within the facility during the
pandemic what is quite unique the second
thing that has happened is many
customers were couldn't interact face to
face with us
um moving from a world where the
interaction happened face to face into a
world of interaction didn't happen at
all and suddenly start happening through
so much video it was a phenomenal
Challenge and we were ready to take that
and this is one of the things that the
pandemic has helped us that also has put
ourselves closer to customers right now
when the pandemic is is disappearing we
are coming back to a more normal life we
have to adapt to this new reality
without losing some of the value of the
of the digital interaction that we are
having but it itself it created
challenges and we have to adapt at
ourselves so we have to start sharing
who we want to video to online
communication through different
interactions and sometimes the missing
of the face-to-face interaction the
human touch really create discrepancies
and disconnections in the relationship
that the simulator you have to fix and
you have to address so this is one of
the elements that I think the pandemic
is is it has been a big impact the the
second part that I would say that
happened during this time is uh all the
supply chain issues has changed the way
that the world is working we used to
really what they would call a role of
abundance so we could ask for anything
and everything was shipped to us and we
could receive uh enough materials not
only in the companies like value but
even our homes and we would be able to
access those things right now a supply
chain has totally changed uh
in the world and and we have to adapt
ourselves both companies like some of
who are suppliers and companies like us
who are receiving those things and we
have to really ready to be ready to
understand how we're going to live to a
different different time in this market
of a AV that that's what we do the other
component that some of the raw materials
is coming from plasmid and those plasma
need to be right at the time again all
this combination of when things are
ready for doing those different things
are important and they never happened at
the time during the pandemic on top of
that we saw a Slowdown in clinical
trials recruiting clinical trust was not
a priority
um the priority was finding a vaccine
people were scared to go to hospital so
we saw a cross on the field and across
all fields in the industry a huge as
well around clinical trials that means
that some Productions were planned to
happen may not happen at the time it may
have to delay so there was a lot of
adjustment to the the teams different
organization so I think that the science
has been Magnificent the question right
now for me is more what do we learn
about how we're going to get all of that
in uh in a world that we can come back
to a normal operation but with the
learning of what happened to us over the
last two years that we're trying to
forget what happened but we tend to
remember the anecdotes but I think it's
very important to learn the lessons in
particular around the interaction and
the how how to address customer needs in
in remote and how to live in a world
where things are going to continue being
mixed uh what's going to happen with
supply chain and how we're going to
manage the supply chain future and also
important is how companies and customers
are going to start looking at the
clinical trials of the development in
the line of something that is happening
right now that is very very disturbing
is it's a market that is it seems like
it's not looking into biotech as strong
as he was looking uh years ago so there
is also a change in the market through
the high inflation the war in the brain
and all these things that is it's just
putting some of the evaluations of other
companies in the market lower so that's
going to be another challenge in the
market that we have to really understand
how to do because we may need that
there's going to be some real
prioritization and some aspects of the
business need to be thought differently
so we also see them or really really
looking into those things but also we
are really pretty carefully working with
our customers to see how how will be the
best option for them in times where
these challenges are real for for all of
them and eventually it hits us also
well thank you uh so so if I may you
know you observe some changes due to the
pandemic in the way in which you engage
with your customer base and I think
that's um you know Common to the
industry that's um you know a real
Challenge and we've changed as a
consequence of it and then there were
also some internal challenges that you
saw with respect to supply chain
um you know uh trial patient recruitment
for clinical trials
um so there was a lot of different
external and internal factors and
challenges that you had to overcome
I'm wondering if you could talk a little
bit more about some of the bottlenecks
associated with the change in regulatory
landscape
um so I I think Scott uh you know
Gottlieb had talked earlier on in the
program and
um perhaps um we can touch on some of
that regulatory influence here uh due to
the pandemic
well
um the only thing that is happening I
was involving the products to the
agencies is that the the laboratory
expectations are going to higher us
always happens with the new technologies
it happens with Monitor and through all
these years ago it's going to happen
right now with with technology that's
going to happen with mrnas or these
outside of it because there is a lot of
unknowns in this technology and
developeratory bodies are really
defining uh house safety is going to be
measured how we can ensure that the
products really reach standard this the
required one and the conversation that
we have two years ago with agencies are
the the feedback proceed from two years
ago from agencies is changing
automatically now because there is new
new expectations new ways of looking at
the reality on how to develop the
structure what's coming is a constant
conversation between sponsors and the
agency and understanding what are those
new uh regulatory expectations that
people are going to have and because I
said before product
process are so close in this one in in a
pantherapist in particular Indian
therapy and the the importance of the
cmnc packages is absolutely Paramount
and we are seeing uh totally different
set of expectations coming from
customers and coming from Regulators
that we saw two years ago and as more
customers also are moving from phrase
one pool of concept into phase three and
Commercial those expectations are going
higher so I don't think we should be
afraid of that that's I think it's a
great opportunity but it's a good
opportunity also to work together and to
redefine what are these Baseline of uh
regulatory expectations that we are
going to have what are the new
um
essays that we need to to rank what are
the new baselines that we need to have
so that's open for uh an interesting
field about
um r d in the
um interagulatory aspect of the
development of essay so I will give you
an example a potentials is one of the
elements that are really important for
many customers of the agency how we're
going to get a potential that is
Meaningful that can be validated because
you could do the fundamental part for
those so this is an evolving
conversation that is going to really
um put a lot of pressure on sponsors on
us to work together on defining new
methods that can be common foreign
different methods but right now we have
to go to the world with different
lessons and I think that's a very
important area for us to to to to
discuss and an area that is going to
require tremendous uh partnership
between uh sponsors and cdmos to to
really understand what are the
expectations and also how we can better
bring our experience and our resources
to solve the particular problems the
particular questions that they are
getting from regulators and the more we
plan the more we work on that the better
so bottom line but this is not going to
be the traditional you give me something
I produce to you and here's the product
is is a policy that is going to combine
manufacturing obviously as the process
of the good produce product but a lot of
r d and a lot of a conversation with
customers to to Really share our
information share how we're going to get
to those details and those being part of
the
um submission to the to the ISC we have
a a big advantage in our uh way of doing
business in aib because we have a common
process so we have created a years ago
on on
respond that we can be a reference for
everybody I think we have to go One Step
Beyond that
um that really helped a lot in the last
days but now moving forward this drug
must have found it to be probably more
complete we need to add more things to
that in particular following customer
expectations around how they want to
present the problem in front of The
Regulators so more and more and I think
this is natural
many of these sponsor major these
customers are really getting closer to
the market and the expectation from City
most are different so that's when we
created margin commercial we have that
image so that's our challenge for the
next couple of years to to Really
transition from
venusidimo who was doing a clinical
staff to do a CDM office doing phase
three and commercial stuff in the way
that The Regulators are expecting in the
way that can be delivered to patients
with equality and of course that
everyone is expecting
um wonderful insights I I know that
there are also challenges that we see on
the horizon with respect to
harmonization of global regulatory
requirements so
um you know how we practice in Spain
um versus you know the FDA and and some
of the practices
um within the United States are always
presenting some some challenges until
the industry settles down a bit but I
also look forward to better
harmonization of some of the regulatory
uh requirements in the future
no matter what because uh but it's been
um
all my time in the industry always
unissued as of how the agencies are
working together I think is is much
better than years ago but still every
time there is a new morality
with coming back to our study which uh
who's going to lead that and who's going
to follow and how how agencies can react
together and harmonize is very important
but right now I don't think we are in
that ideal situation where the
harmonization is global I don't think
that says still there but we are getting
closer but it's going to take more work
that's right that's right so maybe we
could broaden it a little bit
um you know within the current global
position and
the pandemic to the Russia Ukraine
conflict that I think you alluded to a
little earlier what are the key areas of
uncertainty for gene therapy again the
industry at large and what concerns you
the most
well and the wars has gone through
instrumental exchange with the in the
pandemic we're very happy that we found
that thingy and and people need to
understand that the the fact that we
have I've seen our companies and
scientists scientists Creator vaccine
and Compass were able to manufacture
billions of that is a not remarkable
effort but historical effort and once I
thought that we were already out of that
and people were going to look at the
industry as a an industry who was going
to really change the Dynamics of the
Pharmaceuticals on the way drugs have
been developed in the world and the way
we're going to treat diseases we have
seen the work of crane and how the
inflation and however things that are
really shaking the market quite a lot
I've been shocked to see that many of
the companies who were in public last
year in the NASDAQ
are I would say hit percentage of those
are really trading below the entry form
in actual and that's that's a signal
that what the market is weak and some
companies are really trading uh lower
than the traffic having hand so this is
a war zone signal for uh
companies and ideas are coming from
entrepreneurs these investors private
Equity that they are really want to
drive this Innovation forward so what I
think it works these two things is
companies doing trade-offs that will be
difficult
in light of the situation that we have
and also investors who may not be
patient with the sector and I think we
need both we need uh ideas to flow with
the Innovation to to flow within capital
and there's enough capital in the world
but we need the capital to flow in this
in this chapter but we need investors to
be patient we need investors to be
patient with it because uh nothing is
simple in this drug development process
people can tell you that when these new
technology this new technology would be
much better than before we're going to
get much more advances but at the
university the ABC of
the drug development in the sense the
process need to be reversed the nodes
are update we know of human biology
better but still we don't know
everything so we are in evolution so
what I would call this a situation right
now we are in the Buddha similarity with
the computer uh world we are kind of the
era of Windows 3.1 I'm ready to go to
the next version of Windows because this
technology is in itself are not the end
of the story they are Evolution the
reason why we could have new
technologies 10 years from now is
because we have the current technology
right now so we we are starting with a
in therapy we have mrnas we are going to
engineering we are going to go into
non-viral we're going to see all kind of
things sort of RNA requirements a lot of
new technologies coming but if we miss a
step in the development and if we miss a
an inflection point we may be put a
Jeopardy the rest of the evolution of
this and I think that's what bothers me
at this point is that the the journey to
really cure diseases like Alzheimer's
and Parkinson's and uh cardio software
failure seasons are really important
decisions in the world really depends
heavily on the investment on this upon
therapist
um if we don't see that we see a big
period of capital not flowing to
companies uh people not be able to to
move things from their lab into the into
the market because there is the
difficulties to to finance those
companies we are going to pay the price
of society so I think that's my major
concerned that that evolution is very
important it's like everything you need
time to to evolve and you need the
resources to evolve and you tell me what
words mean not as a CEO of bargain
because I think that we have a number of
customers we have projects but it's most
Society thinks technology needs to
evolve I need to have
um we need to have bigger aspirations
but that means a good working plans and
good Capital to really make those things
happen and my worries are now we we have
a resolution focus a little bit and I'm
making the the market a little bit slow
at the time that we need those ideas to
progress
yeah so um great segue to maybe um you
know my next question which is
um
how do you see your participation as a
cdmo in the gene therapy Market changing
in the next three to five years do you
think that gene therapy will continue to
rely mainly on aav uh vectors or do you
see a change to you know non-viral
um so just trying to get a sense of you
know key changes that you're
anticipating
well whoever thinks that the technology
they're using is going to stay forever
it hasn't learned that lesson from
history so we know that AV is maybe a
component that is not the only component
in this in this market we are seeing
that right now
um but I would say that um the business
of cdmo for Advanced Therapy is the
business of crmo for abs it's a business
based on knowledge so business based on
the so when I look at the business value
the main aspect of our business is not
the production the main aspect of our
business is the rmd that goes around the
production so what we are doing as we
speak and we are doing all the time is
investing in on the investing in first
ways to improve the process second ways
to to Really reach out to other
moralities with AVS and ways to also
bring other things to the table so in my
view this is the the road that the
innovators need to do the only way to
not to be obsolete is to innovate and
with an innovate weapon to me actually
so we can have a lot of success today in
the next five years but if the market
change in the next five years will be in
trouble so that's the discussion that
we're having constantly internally and
with our
shareholders with a with barrier I'm
also with um with Aspire that Innovation
is absolutely free however while this
time comes we need to innovate also why
we saw our customers and what we are
looking right now is in providing the
right information for those humancy
packages and we are going to be much
more aggressive in how
to become a better prepared to have a
lot of conversations we believe that
that's a way to to make the future
better so the future of Av in particular
depends heavily on how many products get
to the market using a b so our role in
that experimental and we are going to do
what it takes to really partner with
contacts and to promote and help them to
to get to the market faster uh faster in
the means of time but faster in the
being of being more prepared and faster
in the in the way of really having more
Play Store personal Goods much relatable
ways to relieve and adjust the market
when peace goes down because right now
and the reality is there is very few
products approved for a bit right now
but there will be more in the in the
future so the future of the morality is
going to require depend heavily on the
success of this new products going into
the market
right and some of those products include
potentially lipid nanoparticles or maybe
exosomes or you know other Technologies
and I'm wondering you know what
technology hurdles
um are you seeing uh currently within
viral gen's effort to advance gene
therapy forward
well we we know that
um
for our field to evolve and and to about
whether they we need to have new
plasmids a plasma that has a better
functionality we are working on that
through
our plans with
AV we have to do things related to new
cell lines that are really
helping us to get better deals we need
to really also start looking at how we
can use AVS to do uh somethings around
genetic in a small way we are working
also on on fees so we all have all these
things that we are working in parallel
and also we are looking in or what other
Technologies are going to have in the
market that we may have to transition to
from aav to be part of this process
Evolution so we have the roadmap already
and we have those those things working
on what is important is as I said before
is that you have to have a very good
mindset around around that you almost
look yourself as a you will be um
actually in the next five years what
what are you going to do looking at the
market is very important and really
exploring on the exploring new
technologies licensing new technologies
is very useful and we have a mindset and
we have that roadmap already in place
but as I said for the next three years
what our customers are going to see are
going to be services that are going to
happen to be better prepared to address
the commercial conversation on the
Facebook conversation and if we identify
new technologies that can really make
them more suitable in the easy field or
evolving from The Av field will be ready
for that because at the end of the day
it's a question of uh ballading came as
a combination of technology and white
people and again we have the right
people the technology is just a question
of finding the writing audience doing
the transition when that transition will
happen time will tell
but we believe there's going to be an
evolution and also some technologies
will purchase so we are seeing MRI has
been been a feel of interest and not a
party person lnps with a
non-violence is going to be important at
the end of the day as I said before it's
an evolution we need to be part of the
Revolution we are not going to evaluate
everything or nothing and and we have to
be also finding our space and we are
finding our space because we are doing
things in different spaces at this point
with different customers
great well let's pivot to customers
um in your experience uh in working with
customers what do you think are their
most urgent needs and and how do they
work with you effectively
well our customers really
come from different models it depends so
you have the customers who come out a
lot but really it has a great idea a
great project and they need to really go
into a uh let's let me see if this works
or let me see if I can raise uh Capital
to get to the next stage that customer
has a need that is very particular the
the need is I need to prove something
very quick I need to know that works
because time is essential for me to go
to the next stage so those customers are
early estate customers who are coming as
in other universities and development
labs and and these customers really can
come to us and say how long would you
partner with us because
then we have the ability from a small
Trader run to predict what's going to
happen into a 2000 liter run and we can
show them this is what we are going to
see but we're going to give you what you
need at this point that's disability to
really understand what's going to happen
this is one type of customers there are
customers who are coming to us whether
they are okay I'm going to go into
playing control
but I need to know if if really I can
really make this screen control work and
how I I need to prove that it's going to
be economically viable and also I need
to do a lot of materials and can you do
that for me well that's a technical type
of customer and we need to show them
well and then you have customers who are
evolving more into any football now into
a phase three I need to do comparability
you need to do understanding how I'm
going to present this into them from the
FDA of the EMA I need to understand how
the package of information is going to
be comprehensive and strong so I can't
really have a conversation and they need
different things so I would say every
customer will need different things at
the stage of development and we need to
really understand how I want to solve
all of them better at the end of the day
the components of r d and the components
of information is absolutely key and you
look at the bargain we are not only a
manufacturing shop that can create using
protein a great deal of performance in
terms software production but we are
manufacturing a group that is doing
developmental energy that also can
produce information for you that can
really with your submission because we
do the same process across all the
products so when we do something with
for instance 89 we do a lot of 89 so we
really have a lot of speeds around the
running so when we present your package
we can really base our information all
these things we have 89 in in our in our
process because the process is the same
if you are trying to do a compatibility
study we can really help you from the
two liter run into the 200 meter run and
we can really help you with information
that we needed so I think that we offer
a number of things and each customer
obviously is going to customize those
needs in particular using taking
advantage of our process and also we are
going to be pre-open to help the
customers to see how our information our
data can really suit their needs in
terms of preparation for the submission
to the agencies so that's what I think
um we can do and we can do the best and
and this is what I think is going to
differentiate us however this is going
to be different from different customers
because they are going to be a different
stage everywhere and they need to
understand that but when someone comes
to us we want to project where do you
want to be in three years but you're
driving in five years and rather than
pressing needs that you have and how you
are trying to go there and we can
partner with them
yes perhaps irrespective of where they
are in their Journey
um you know the level of partnership and
relationship building that you have with
your customers
um is really going to be I think a
driving force for
um viral gen and I'm wondering how you
specifically define success with your
customers
well and let me give you an example of
how we define success we we do something
very unique also in Biogen we as I said
we are very committed to the success of
customers but our customers again is a
patient is the patient will take the the
the the the the
therapy that we we produce and one thing
we are doing and we are partnering with
the Columbus Venture Partners we have a
there are a number of uh products or
opportunities in the market that there
is no uh commercial interest there is no
commercial opportunity for them nobody
will invest money because there is no
money to be made and they are coming
from patient associations they're coming
from uh Russia's groups and these are
really using Technologies like the AV
that really are suitable to solve them
so you are able to solve a problem for a
duchenne or for Pompeo for other
diseases you can sort out the same
problem for
juvenile Parkinson for human pick a for
spd50 for many diseases who the number
of people are not kids in the world are
available so for us success is a
being able to bring products to these
people being products to these
organizations are really not capable of
that because nobody's going to put their
money so what we do is we dedicate our
efforts to provide access and to provide
a perhaps for those organizations who
are never going to have the the
financial means to to do those things
but they have different power and they
have the motivation they have the the
ability to really change the world
through what they do with with patients
so for instance we are we are working
very closely on on the ABC Community
we're working very closely on spd50 so
we have already products that we are
putting in half of the customers that we
don't make a profit for them but we are
making an impact and for us success is
impacting success in Impact we have in
the people in the community such as the
team that we have in those kids because
at the end of the day
um
customers are the final customers
adaptations and we want to make sure
that people about them understand that
and that's where we'll go into that
journey of saying we're going to help
people also where we don't have any
economic return it doesn't matter to us
but what it matters is the impact that
we do and that's I think that's very
important for us to to Really continue
that so back to your question how
success to the customers is measured in
impact on on patients and we have in our
town hall here everyone again patience
and the kids with their families coming
after they've been treated or kids who
have a lot to be treated for kids that
will never be treated because
the solution will never come on time for
them because what I want in all the
employees are about them to know is that
they have a bigger responsibility than
just producing they have a reference
other activity because the lives of many
or the hope of many people is in the
hands and that's what I think is going
to differentiate City most in the future
from those who are just turning products
into those that are really helping
others to to to to be successful in
particular patients to save their lives
because fortunately the drugs that we
produce the products that we do are
saving people lives unfortunately we
cannot save as many as possible as many
as we can because again it takes time
there are many diseases but we have to
take very big pride in the things that
we do right and the things that we do
that really have an impact on people
great examples of really how you're
fulfilling your mission to increase the
accessibility of these um Gene therapies
to patients so um I applaud your efforts
there
um you know we all know that customers
are constantly evolving technology is
evolving how do you plan
um and adapt your organization to new
requests and new changes in the
marketplace
well it's um
uh as I said before the only way to
adapt to change in the market is to be
part of those changes and to do around
the use of and to be very connected with
the AMD war on see what's coming and uh
what's going to be
that technology that can put your our
Market or what's the technology that
really can make you stronger in the
market so we have access to new
developments we are working with
different r d groups in in Australia we
apply all the r d that comes from there
we are also connecting with other
research groups and we are doing our
best to understand what's going to come
down on the line new new new promoters
new new capsids new
um classmates new cell lines all these
things are under our radar we are
looking into those and we are willing to
engage with organizations to to see how
these things can improve the way the
business is done because keep keep in
mind that at the end of the day the
success of what we do is going to come
from to us quality and performance the
quality of the product and performance
of the product in the market meaning are
we really doing the things that we need
to do in terms of change the
um that particular disease and also it's
about cost
I will do that for the cost that is
reasonable because as you know they
imagine for a moment that we find a
solution for
um uh Parkinson's for assignments but we
say well the the manufacturing of this
is going to be around 2 million dollars
a piece well it won't work it was saying
that with the vaccines in profit uh the
reaction in profit the cost of goods was
a real issue at the beginning and has to
improve so I think when when the market
really finds
um the motivation to make things happen
and the technology will come and people
need to bring those pieces together so
this is not similar to us so the more
customers we are getting commercial the
more we need to have them how to really
partner with them in that process but
because it's quality and performance and
those are the two things that we need to
be very very religion and I think that's
a important however uh when you bring
new technologies you can really both
increase quality but you may take some
time because you have to reduce some of
the essays and some of the things that
to make that mainstream but also you can
Will introduce new technology to be much
more efficient and really gain on that
performance part so uh r d
it need to happen if you don't do around
it you're not part of the future the
future will you'll find your future by
Serendipity but you have to be attached
to some around the component that really
allow you to really find the future
yourself and I think that's fundamental
for us
so um let me touch on
um our partnership
um so between viral gin and Thermo
Fisher Scientific I'd like to understand
how Partners like us can most
effectively work with cdmos to achieve
um increased Heights of accomplishment
and quality and in performance and
really move the industry forward even
toward more standardization of how we
create and manufacture Gene Therapies
well I would say thermal vision has been
a great problem from the beginning and I
would also Define that in a stage as you
were a great partner when we started
business and here in France Sebastian
and very few people knew where Santa
asking was
um you were able to come by the area so
we hope you will will provide the
equipment and we provide what's needed
for you to be successful and that's what
I think is is the average stage of our
Pharmacy so you you really saw the
opportunity on us we saw that they need
to have someone that we trust and and we
build that but I would say that they see
partnership and the more difficult
partnership when you start going to
growth and bigger opportunities but also
with that come bigger problems and we
come different discussions that we need
to have and I think in in the in the
case of um farmer in particular the
whole situation with supply chain has
become a real issue a real bottleneck
and I think we have been able to
navigate that
um without very much openness in terms
of how we communicate it and also how we
expressed to you what are the needs that
we have yesterday to ask these are the
issues we are facing and let's work
together on those unless really find a
solution to your point I think there are
ways to to get out of this I wouldn't
like to be in this situation forever in
which uh we are driving like driving a
car and not knowing what you are going
to be around our gas but at the end of
the day you you find a solution I think
the world needs to evolve from this
level of um we like to have a huge
portfolio products into something more
understanding because it will be in
everybody's interest and we are happy to
do our part to to make sure that you
also saw a provider of very important
materials very important elements uh
that they are not just
um disposable things they are essential
to the to the process and we can help
you to be more successful we can help
you to to plan better we can help you to
reduce the number of uh call items in
your Warehouse or you can use themselves
ten thousand you can use uh 2 000 items
and we'll be happy to to work that I
think the war is going to uh
much more standardization and this war
of abundance and we have to be different
people who use one component for you
that is different and the company they
use in a different component is over but
what I appreciate more around the
partnership
because the products are given so people
if you don't bring the right products is
is
um is is you'll have the picture but
many companies bring similar products
but I think what differentiate Partners
from others is the attitude to problems
is the ability to have conversations is
ability to understand and to have an
empathy around how we want to solve
different things and and I believe
strongly that the difference is made by
people and not by companies and we found
in other offices the people who are
ready to listen even in tough situations
we are able to escalating and we are
able to have conversations for instance
I give you an example and this weeks
from this week
um Dr Houston was in Madrid
he received an award for the Washington
town with the the foundation and for the
science he has been doing and he gave a
talk in Madrid so there was a meeting
from the commercial team from Thermo uh
the European team in Madrid so I sent
him an invitation and the whole team
that was Madrid came to listen to the
presentation so
that means a lot to to us but also it
showed us the level of commitment the
level of partnership that someone was
willing to put with us because
people could be visiting Madrid at seven
o'clock and doing all things but they
decided to come to a meeting and from
the sales people the commercial people
in Europe to to the senior vice
president they all were in the
conference and they all were actually
there's a picture running around with
with all of us together but for me
that's that's the difference that you
you happy people who willing to
appreciate what we have done you are
part of this project from the beginning
because you saw that started from where
we were a small shop and now we have
much bigger place and and we really
appreciate that and I think it's
important that we continue that
conversation but it's not only about
products about how people are willing to
start a conversation at a different
level that approach it was not important
and for us for you uh what we have in
mind is the patient and that's that's
very critical and you've been also
instrumental in some of the things we
have been doing with our foundation in
terms of really raising the awareness of
people saying what can we do to make
sure that people know that there are
people that need help but we are
counting on you and doing that so we I
think we share some things about common
ground for us to grow and that's the
basic of the partnership
yeah Javier customers are at the heart
of everything that we do so it's
gratifying to hear um that you know
we're bought into your success and um
we're curious to learn more about your
success so
um thank you for sharing that example
as we close out our time here today I'd
like to maybe hear your Reflections on
your five year long journey
um you know that you've had With viral
gin um you've obviously had a longer
history with the foundation but what
achievements here and even extending to
the Columbus uh Children's Foundation
are you most proud of
well I really answered this question I
tell you a secret because when I came
here to Value as an investor I was going
to be here for three months that was the
plan that we have so I'll be here three
months I will find a CEO I will move
aside to be an investor I will do all
things while the three months has become
five years
um I have to say that in high tech I
never thought it was going to be like
this but if I look back about what a
comparison with my whole career I think
this is the best
delivery I have in my whole career that
it just came I would say from the heart
it came from really making fun something
I really believe that was providing a
different for patient but at the same
time likely to sometimes opportunities
to do things and and this was one
unfortunately I was able to grab it but
then it will have passed by and not been
able to to take it but right now I feel
like it's extremely I'm typically
grateful that I was given this
opportunity so having said that if I
look back at the learnings there are
three things one is when you begin these
things this project are not very
ambitious you have to have a vision you
have to have a vision that is aggressive
that is
um original but also that is
transformative and very quickly you need
to really start asking yourself why this
vision is possible and in this
particular case three things happen here
that really make the difference once
technology that we were talking about a
great technology that was
the best of the world ready to deliver a
very well proven and at the same time
that it was available to us with the
awareness practice from from Judson
working system the second one is are you
really will to build on a team that is
committed around this a team that is
going to be committed to deliver on
Division and that means ready to run
implementation plan ready to go ready to
grow with you around that and I was very
lucky to start recruiting the first five
people about them and today having 350
people who are extremely committed to
that and I think as a reflection people
makes the difference again I know it's a
it's almost like a topic but I can tell
you after more than three years in this
industry people make the difference
so you need to to want that and the
third element of this is a an element of
really keeping the patient in the center
because no matter how hard the things
are no matter how difficult things are
some people are having a very difficult
life some people are having an
impossible life and we are the only hope
that we have so for me once you have a
technology that can change the world I
can't change the life of many people you
have an obligation and this is for me
the best glue that can bring everything
together to make this thing happen
because when we look at the parents when
we talk to the parents of this of these
kids who are suffering that haven't ever
seen the diseases they're the real
heroes of the story
and our respect of them and when we have
had time we have discussions and things
are not working together production I I
always tell my team look at the parents
you don't do this some people are going
to die I want to lose their hope our
hope is the only thing they have and we
are the hope so that's for me is the
biggest attraction and basically that's
what's keeping here so at the end of the
day
this is the place where I feel I can
make a better contribution that's why we
created the foundation we created all
the pieces because this is not about
getting an economical return this is
about getting an impact in the world and
I think we are capable of doing that and
and we have an obligation to do that
yeah without even asking the question
again I can see what drives you and
where your passion lies it's um uh it's
really inspirational
um thanks for sharing that
um again we close out are there any
additional key learnings or Reflections
that you'd like to share with this
audience um something that we didn't
cover that you wanted to cover
no I think we cover many aspects and uh
and again I I like to to uh well if they
always have some questions we'll be able
to to answer those uh even live or
offline we can we can answer those happy
to to do those but important is we have
a unique time in history of medicine and
technology and we are in one stage of
evolution so we need to make sure that
we do our best in with this structural
level we are living because we have to
deliver to others a better world and
much better technology and be ready to
really help customers in the best way we
can
well thank you so much Javier for
sharing your Insight today the work that
Viral Jen is doing is incredibly
inspiring and we appreciate the
perspective on how cdmos participate uh
in the advancement of these incredible
Therapies
we wish you continued success in your
journey to broadcast access of Gene
therapies to patients and contribute to
the advancement of Health and Human
welfare around the world again thank you
thank you ready and thank you for Pharma
to inviting me to to share the story
here
it was our pleasure
um so let me switch gears to the next
presentation uh we'll be focusing on
monoclonal antibody early development
and critical considerations for
commercialization Success so you don't
want to miss it
um and in closing thank you all for your
time today and please enjoy the
remainder of Bio process next
[Music]